calves were actually my weakest body  part for a very long time and I actually  had a girlfriend say why don't you train  your calves and I had been training them  for like three years  the fact that she asked me that ruined  my day and then I didn't wear shorts for  three years I did what Arnold did and  started training him first every workout  and I've been doing it since and then I  had only been wearing pants for so long  that I forgot that I stopped wearing  shorts so I was like man I'm getting  really hot I should buy some shorts so I  bought some shorts and I was looking at  myself in the mirror and I was like oh  hello and it was three years since I had  seen it my cat looked way better it'd  been so long and I just forgot why I was  training calves first and then people  started being like Oh your calves aren't  bad now 10 years in